- [whistles]
Anybody here?
It's me by myself.
What's up, Atlanta?
ATL!
What's happening?
What you say?
Over there
with your little fat face
and--and super strong back.
You don't want it over here,
'cause I'll throw 'em.
Boom!
[laughs]
You know, Atlanta,
a lot of people don't know this,
but I can sing.
♪ Did you know that
my first love was music? ♪
♪ Maybe you did
Maybe you didn't ♪
♪ But I'm gonna ask to pet
yo' kitten-ah ♪
[funk music]
♪ Girl, if I could hold
onto your waistline ♪
♪ Make you fall in love ♪
I'ma scat now.
♪ [scatting] ♪
- What the hell you doing?
- I'm trying to make sure
the sound and lights are right.
Y'all ready to shoot?
- We been outside
for 20 minutes.
- Come on, let's go.
Got work to do.
I didn't do nothing.
Let's go.
- What the fuck was that?
♪ ♪